hello and welcome to sunny exeter as you
can tell it's positively tropical here
today
so I'm really looking forward to being
cooled down by you know a bucket of ice
on my head I'd like to thank my friend
Chris sample on Facebook for nominating
me for this challenge this is the mill
encounter support ice bucket challenge
millon are a charity which provide
support to people who've been diagnosed
with cancer and also their families and
it's great cause with my families had to
sort of rely on support like this in the
past so I've all donated ten pounds to
Macmillan I'd encourage you to do the
same
you can donate three pounds by texting
ice or caps if in the UK to seven zero
five five to zero and to make things
more interesting for every one of my
nominations you completes the challenge
in 24 hours I will donate another 10
pounds to Macmillan but before we can do
the nominations I've got a friend here
with a present ah
you
thanks um oh right I'd like to nominate
my friend from home John Harrison my
friend from YouTube
Jaime miles at my friend Collini Joe nor
you have 24 hours I expect to see the
evidence where is it tough